a spirituális élmények vagy a a zene,
van egy csomó olyan dolog, amit
lebutítunk, hogyha elkezdünk szavakkal
méltani, vagy szavakkal reflektálunk
rájuk, és és a művészete egy kicsit
ilyen. Hogyha bemegyünk egy
kiállítótérbe,
szerintem az is jó, hogyha megpróbáljuk
gondolatindítóként konceptuálisan
megfogni azt a valamit, amit látunk.
De mi van akkor, hogyha teljesen
érzelmileg akar, vagy egy olyan olyan
síkon akar ránk hatni a művészet,
amelyhez már fogalom nem feltétlenül
társíthat? És talán ez lesz az AI-nak is
az egyik veszte, vagy vagy talán vissza
fog jönni az emberiségben ez a az igény
arra, hogy hogy megéljük a fogalman túli
dolgokat, mert mert hogy az AI az talán
abban nem fog tudni labdába rúgni, mert
nem tud nem fogalmakkal, vagy nem tudom,
hogy tud meg fog-e tanulni, de ez egy
érdekes dolog, hogy hogy mi az, hogy
spirituális élmény és az, hogy lehet
szavak, lehet-e szavakkás, tud-e bármit
kezdeni ezzel a mesterség intelligencia